dieses virus hatte nun wirklich keiner
auf dem schirm als er seinen urlaub
bucht und große pläne machte und
beschloss endlich seinen träumen
hinterher zu jagen und nun nun sitzt man
irgendwo fest muss irgendwie über die
runden kommen und die zeit totschlagen
und das beste draus machen und
wahrscheinlich geht das in der karibik
besser als anderswo
denn es gibt zweifellos schlimmere orte
an denen man fest stecken könnte in
diesen tagen als an der westküste von
martinique
27 grad hat das karibische badewasser
und im grunde könnte alles perfekt sein
wir sind julia und wir leben seit einem
jahr von seinem segelboot und reisende
eigentlich um die welt aber aufgrund von
carola dürften unser boot derzeit nicht
mehr bewegen
und so haben es die beiden weltumsegler
aus österreich streng genommen nur bis
frankreich geschafft denn das inselchen
der kleinen antillen wird als
überseegebiet vom fernen paris aus
regiert und es gelten strenge regeln
wir dürften zum beispiel wie man das
boot bewegen und dürften lebensmittel
nur mit einer selbsterklärung kaufen und
an land gehen
die maßnahmen wurden zu ostern
verlängert bis 11
seit 30 tagen sind sie mittlerweile hier
in einer art lockt darum deluxe denn
auch im tropenparadies gilt das
vereinzelung geboten worden dass das da
rauskommt tausende segler sitzen fest
auf den eilanden der karibik wo die
häfen geschlossen sind und überall
einreisesperren und ausreiseverbote
gelten die lücken eders können sich
eigentlich noch glücklich schätzen in
ihrer übersichtlichen kleinen haltebucht
uns bewusst dazu entschieden nicht in
einen der größeren orte zu bleiben wo
hunderte und tausende schiffe stehen
weil dort natürlich nicht nur die
ansteckungsgefahr viel höher ist sondern
auch einfach viel mehr los ist für den
supermärkten steht man zwei stunden an
und so also das ist hier schon
wesentlich angenehmer auch auf
martinique ist das virus inzwischen
angekommen gut 200 fälle sind bekannt
zwölf menschenleben hat es schon
gefordert deswegen sicher ist sicher
aber kobe 19 macht den beiden gerade
nicht die größten sorgen sorgen macht
ihnen was ganz anderes
das erfahren wir später zunächst noch
ein anderer einkauf auch in frankreich
aber im nicht karibischen teil des
landes da steckt paul fest der
filmstudent aus ludwigsburg der wollte
unweit von bayern seine freundin und
ihre tochter besuchen aus drei wochen
wurden dann zwei monate aber beklagen
will paul sich nicht im weg
ja da merke ich dann auch dass es mir im
grunde sehr viel schlechter gehen könnte
jetzt gerade
freunde und familie frage mich dann ob
ich hier an den strand gehen kann und
ans meer fahren kann und da meine zeit
verbringen könnte aber obwohl das meer
der atlantik hier 20 kilometer den fluss
lang ist wird da richtig streng
kontrolliert und die polizei
kontrolliert die eingänge zu dem strand
und lässt er niemanden hin wenn man es
trotzdem versucht hast du das straffe
im dorf baguette holen und nach hause
bringen das ist pauls job seine
lebensgefährtin tabea die online
sportartikel vermarktet bestaunt gerade
mit töchterchen anouk hinter dem haus
die kleinen wunder der selbstversorgung
[Musik]
den salami gesät und ich ja als die
quarantäne wurst ging vor vier wochen
sind wir jetzt vier wochen und jetzt
haben wir hier schon die ersten kleinen
salat pflänzchen wahrscheinlich in
quarantäne vorbei ist in frankreich
können wir den ersten salat ernten
bis dahin hilft die freundliche
nachbarin mit selbstgenähten masken aus
ein kleines paradies natürlich mit
einschränkungen
mit der ausgangssperre
außer einkaufen oder so laufen passiert
nicht viel
aber nie allein ist man im home office
ja schön und in ruhe arbeiten verspricht
tabea wohl millionen berufstätigen
müttern aus dem herzen
das ist die australische version von
home office da bewegt lasse im grünen
stapler den teil einer brücke die heute
bauen hilft und zwar im lingala bike
park unweit von prof
da verbringt der backpacker seine corona
zeit leider fernab vom schnellen
internet weswegen seine bilder für uns
etwas grob pixelig ausfallen
aber dafür kann wer ganz genau hinsieht
da links leibhaftige kängurus laufen
sehen
[Applaus]
denn hier mit dem wasser wird das wasser
level der gesamten anlage der gesamten
des gesamten parks wieder aufgefüllt
werden zu viel wasser führt zb ihr viel
rasen oder sowas verwendet wurde um
gegen da haben wir zu versorgen gut das
muss man jetzt nicht genau verstehen
wichtig ist nur dass dieser linga longa
bikepark sportlichen jungen australien
die gelegenheit bietet sich ein
herrlicher natur den hals zu brechen
und da ist backpacker lasse ortmann aus
ratzeburg nun gestrandet nachdem er sich
zwischendurch zur selbstisolation sogar
im wald verkriechen musste hat er es nun
mit diesem bungalow in herrlicher lage
ausnehmend gut getroffen und als es dann
so drastisch war dass ich über ein
rückflug nachgedacht habe und das ganze
mal recherchiert habe sind die preise
für flugtickets eigentlich so so
exorbitant durch die decke geschossen
das teilweise flugticket 12.000 dollar
und mehr gekostet haben und da habe ich
mich selber entschieden
es muss ein weg geben auch hier
irgendwie mit dieser ganzen krise klar
zu kommen und das ganze irgendwie zu
überwinden
durch einen hilferuf auf facebook kamen
er und seine kumpels schließlich im
bikepark unter wo sie sich mit ihrem
handwerklichen geschick schnell
unverzichtbar gemacht haben zum beispiel
heute eben beim bau der bereits
erwähnten brücke der park in dem man
nicht nur radfahren sondern auch
heiraten und pizza essen kann ist gerade
corona bedingt im leerlauf und da ist
natürlich jede menge auszubessern zu
sägen zu hobeln und zu bohren und lasse
ist froh dass er sich vom virus nicht
vertreiben ließ wir sind immer noch hier
inzwischen in der dritten woche geht es
blendend
wir kommen super gut durch die krise um
ganz ehrlich zu sein ist es sogar so
dass das ein platz ist wo man wo man das
eigentlich alles so ein bisschen wieder
vergisst weil man weil man so
abgeschottet ist von der welt von dem
ganzen um rom
ja das macht es macht es recht einfach
durch diese krise durch zu kommen
und wieder einmal bewahrheitet sich die
alte backpacker weisheit es kommen auch
wieder bessere tage
wer gern im auto sitzt für den ist sie
die traumstraße schlechthin
die panamericana von patagonien bis
alaska wollten die kurzen reisen aber
jetzt stecken sie fest in der
trockensten wüste der welt wo die nächte
bitter kalt und einsam sind aber das
kann die extrem kämpfer nicht
erschüttern
seit wochen grüßt am wüsten raum täglich
das murmeltier
ja hallo ich bin michael und zusammen
sind sie die kursmarken und wir reisen
die welt ja derzeit sitzen mehrheit in
südamerika genauer gesagt im norden von
chile in der atacama erwarten bis an die
grenzen offen ist richtung caron
soweit der plan schauen wir wie lange es
dauert die günstigsten prognosen machen
immerhin etwas mut so wie es jetzt
aussieht wird es ende april hoffen wir
mal dass der letzte stand jetzt mal in
deutschland ja auch nicht gerade lustig
und so doch dein dortmund aber ich lese
gerade noch die nachrichten
und das ist möglich weil die wüste nicht
nur lebt sondern auch handyempfang kennt
das hilft gegen heimweh
es gibt natürlich diese rückholaktionen
richtung europa deutschland und so
weiter das kommt für mich nicht in frage
wir wollen uns in reisegefährten unser
ordnung nicht hier lassen
nur wenn es mal mit dem fahrrad in die
nächste stadt geht dann lassen sie den
reisegefährten das auto doch mal ein
paar stunden allein
der komplex menschenleer
ganz neu für einzelpersonen die stadt
eigentlich sehr schön aber die
ausrichtung partner die hunde hier wenn
man bedenkt dass anbieter atacama
eigentliche touristenhochburg anfang
märz gewesen ist es eine geisterstadt in
der es beim getränkehandel immerhin noch
einen ganz passablen rotwein gibt und
nicht ohne eine spur von neid bemerken
wir dass im supermarkt die regale da
hinten also die mit dem klopapier
deutlich besser gefüllt sind als bei uns
menschen in wüsten randlage scheinen
also in der not andere prioritäten zu
setzen als wir sämtliche haus sondern
sich auch geschlossen
aus den letzten posten ausziehen musste
wohl dem der einigermaßen bequem in
seinem auto schlafen kann
in dieser unübersichtlichen zeit apropos
zeit
es wird zeit wieder nach martinique zu
schauen wo julia und markus lucke neder
nach ihrem ausflug an land wieder einmal
sehr dankbar dafür sind dass sie immer
genügend frischwasser zum händewaschen
im tank haben
überhaupt sind die beiden ja so was wie
experten in vorrats fragen viele
lebensmittel an bord also hamsterkäufe
sind für uns eigentlich alltag bekommt
dann kaufte was man kriegen kann und
bunkern kann bloß nutzt der best
bestückte vorratsraum nichts wenn einem
plötzlich die geschäftsgrundlage
entzogen wird wie so vielen in diesen
tagen einem gewissen grad trifft uns die
krise auch wirtschaftlich weil wir die
reise so finanzieren dass wir gäste
mitnehmen
diese saison natürlich viele buchungen
stornieren müssen und haben dann kulant
halber auch die amt
zahlungen zurück überwiesen weil wir ja
nicht wissen waren reisen wieder möglich
sein wird und jetzt beginnt auch noch
bald die hurrikansaison da müssten sie
sich und ihre yacht eigentlich in
sicherheit bringen
aber es scheint dafür nur schlechte
lösungen zu geben auf renterin norden in
die usa da können wir leider kein visum
mehr oder marcel zurück nach europa
dieses jahr gefährlicher weg überhaupt
weil dieses jahr müssten durch sehen
also man kann sehr schwer zwischenstopps
machen also maskierter 35 bis 40 tage
unterwegs und das ist schon eine weite
strecke oder was sie drunter weiter in
den süden auch prädikat und tobago oder
zumindest noch das ist aber nur
unsichere also die medizinische
versorgung ist auf diesen inseln
urschlechter und da gibt es ja wirklich
eine große vielzahl von infizierten
so und jetzt mal so ein trick der nur im
fernsehen funktioniert wir springen mit
julia und markus ins karibische wasser
und tauchen mit judith edel in der bali
sie wieder auf
da hat die junge frau aus hannover
nämlich seit ein paar jahren eine
tauchschule auf einer mikroskopisch
kleinen insel zwischen bali und lombok
wo sich die meeresschildkröten sehr wohl
fühlen die menschen auch jedenfalls bis
dann
nun sind die strände leer die gäste
geflüchtet oder vertrieben und auch
judith darf nicht weg ausreisesperre wie
man sehen kann ist hier momentan
niemand mehr natürlich nicht zu
vergessen ist ist dass wir hier
diesen ausblick haben wer natürlich
alles ein bisschen erträglicher macht
ist doch schön wenn sich judith daran
nach so vielen jahren immer noch
erfreuen kann
denn so viel freude haben ja
reiselustige und reiseveranstalter zur
zeit nicht umso erstaunlicher dass es
einen ort gibt an denen die touristen
trübsal ganz schnell vertrieben werden
kann zum beispiel mit einem kleinen
federball turnier dieser ort liegt tief
im dschungel von guatemala wo sich
zwischen tropenholz und papageien
nestern eine gruppe von tiefen
entspannten aussteigern zur nudel
mahlzeit versammelt ja gemeinsam essen
ist hier noch ohne plexiglasscheiben
möglich denn die 20 gäste im öko hotel
utopia sind alle gemeinsam im lock down
mit ihnen auch ein wirtschaftsstudent
aus bayreuth
hallo mein name ist nicht ehrlich bin 21
jahre alt und lebe aktuell in guatemala
ich bin mit 20 anderen touristen im eck
youtube im hotel gestrandet einem hotel
mitten im dschungel nähe des
nationalparks dem pace die touristen die
nach hause mussten haben es geschafft
indem sie nach mexiko ausgereist sind
und wir da ein flug genommen haben oder
auf einem der rückflüge nach deutschland
gewartet haben für mich kam das nicht
betracht da ich keine eile habe zu hause
zu sein
ich bin student und die universitäten
haben die lehre digitalisiert wodurch
ich einfach von hier studieren kann und
dazu sammelt er auch praktische
erfahrungen in berufs nahen disziplinen
zum beispiel in der kakao plantagen des
herbergsvater die man tut mir auslegen
müssen alle zwei stunden wenden muss
alle zwei stunden wenden sollte man sich
auch beim sonnenbad am dschungel fluss
wo es wenn überhaupt mal zu kontakten
mit den einheimischen kommen könnte die
da hinten manchmal fischen aber die
kontakte sind locals schränken wir eher
ein
auf einer gemeindeversammlung
herausgekommen ist dass die mehrheit der
bevölkerung hier angst vor uns hat
denken dass jeder träger des virus sind
und halten sich deshalb von uns fern
umso näher kommen sich die wackeren
dschungelcamper dann bei ihren
zahlreichen quarantäne aktivitäten
sitzen alle im gleichen boot und sie
mittlerweile schon über einen monat
jetzt könnte man meinen es wird
langweilig aber das stimmt so nicht
ich habe ziemlich viel zu tun morgens
haben yoga ritual
danach haben wir 31 workout und
ansonsten vertreiben unsere zeit mit
gesellschaftsspielen lernt spanisch oder
kühlen zum schluss ab
[Applaus]
und immer wieder gibt es auch mal was zu
feiern
und so sind sie auch im paradies für
aussteiger dem ende des lockouts wieder
einen tag näher gekommen
[Musik]
und wenn es abend der köstliche duft von
bratkartoffeln bohnen und würstchen vom
lager der kurzen über die wüste atacama
weht und dann über den anden die nacht
heraufzieht dann ist man dem himmel
nirgends näher als hier wo höhenluft und
wüstenklima das firmament zum leuchten
bringen
im paradies für sternengucker
[Musik]
und wenn im segler paradies karibik die
sonne untergeht dann brechen julia und
markus auf zu ihrem allabendlichen
ritual dem sundowner mit den anderen
seglern die wie sie hier ankern und
nicht wissen wie lange noch
aber eins wissen sie gemeinsam ist immer
besser als einsam und vielleicht kennen
auch sie die alte backpacker weisheit es
kommen auch wieder bessere tage
obwohl die jetzt vielleicht auch nicht
so schlimm sind
[Musik]